[Music]
howard doss
shawn larkin man we are still here at
crime con 2022 in las vegas and uh we've
been very fortunate banging out a bunch
of
guests they're all here man they are
everybody's here to talk to you i tell
you what blown away by is the number of
people that are here for this thing i
think they said
i've heard numbers like 20 000 signed up
to attend i don't know if that's the
correct number but uh there are a lot of
true crime junkies out there yeah
they're solving crimes from their arm
they are they are well uh here on uh our
episode today of cocktails and cocktails
we got a great guest we have a great
guest we have a a guy who is a legend in
the true crime world from a uh different
perspective of actual
you know being a cop but he's been a
boot on the ground and covering
literally the biggest cases that have
happened over the last 20 plus years
across the country and including one
right now i know that his network has
just been hammering out coverage on on
the johnny depp trial
that's going on but we've got one and
only good personal friend of mine dan
abrams gentlemen it's good to be here
it's good to be here this is a rarity
because you know uh obviously our time
together doing the show you're the host
you're the guy running things i've been
on
the dan abrams hour there on the uh
on on your siriusxm show i've been on
there a handful of times obviously
you've got your the dan abrams show or
our you know the the new on news nation
right now that i i'm on there regularly
with so this is kind of nice me being in
charge here yeah i want to see how you
do yeah
oh we also have to say we have to refer
to him as el jefe because he's our boss
he is he is the boss so uh but dan as
you well know
well you know what we're actually going
to discuss this
we're going to discuss that we're going
to talk about the name of this podcast
at some point but it is called cocktails
and cocktails um so people tell you guys
that they love the name nonstop i know
it's sort of like the guy who walks in
with the pink tie with the polka dots
people are like sweet thai man and he's
like oh that's and he's like and he's
like everyone loves my tie look at this
man everywhere i go people are like this
ties it's called being bold and stepping
out is what it is
uh but this bottle we're drinking right
here today is a uh an old elk barrel
pick that we did with one of our friends
by the name of dirk who owns mary's
liquor in tahlequah oklahoma and uh we
did a pick we got the whole barrel
bottled up and we saved this one
specifically to drink while we are here
until you got here because
it has uh even on the label it's got
howard and i with the cocktails and
cocktails our little characters it's
just a great name it's a fantastic name
yeah
so we'll have a little bump
here it's pretty smooth
that's as smooth as the name
it's nice it is nice yeah
um um real quick we actually talk about
the bourbon stuff i guess and i know
everybody likes hearing you know live pd
and all that but
i didn't drink bourbon at all neither
did i no that's right i i neither of us
drank bourbon ever
now i'm a you're an affectionator and
you are hardcore i am yeah i've gone all
in yeah yeah so what after the show you
know on live pd every from the beginning
it was friday and saturday we'd hang
around and have have cocktails and pizza
that they would have up there for us but
then it turned into an every friday
thing and
obviously that was my first stand in
television dan's been in the business
what 30 years roughly scary yeah 30
years yeah um and you know talking
whether it be dan or somebody else that
worked on the show
everybody said that this was such a
unique situation there you had a hit
show where everybody got along and
everybody i mean that you would use the
word family and
you had a vp for a e that was their
every show and you had the production
assistants you know the people that are
literally running and getting coffees
and cleaning up the dinner that was
there and stuff like that
everybody knew each other got along i
mean there was i don't know 80 people
probably there a night maybe at that
show 100 i mean there were there were a
lot of people that were involved in
making the show if you include the
cruise yeah exactly
so on friday night when it ended you
know went off the air at midnight
you know we're all running taking off uh
you know changing clothes that type of
thing and then within 10 minutes
it didn't matter who you were that were
that were part of the production you
were in there having a cocktail together
and we would stay around some nights for
two two hours well because our weekends
were shot right right right yeah we have
no weeks saturday nights we're gone so
it's like all right if we're going to do
anything it's going to be here it's here
yeah yeah that's great that's one of the
things i miss most about oh absolutely i
mean there might have been
like
i mean out of the number of episodes
that we did there there might have been
three times like when the show ended we
went out somewhere yeah and it was
everybody just stood there so going into
that i was a beer guy i think dan was a
wine guy who now owns a winery by the
way congratulations on that so who was
the gateway to the wonderful worlds of
the elixir of corn liquor for you guys
you know it was it was a couple of the
guys um
um
it was one of the audio guys
yeah because they used to do their own
they had their own room yeah so
basically what would happen initially
was like the whole audio team
had their own
we had like a wine thing and like some
food and stuff and these guys were all
sitting there
having bourbon
and so we were like you know at one
point at some point we're like hey why
are we not doing you know why aren't you
guys coming out and this and that and so
um eventually they did and and zito was
into into bourbon uh the executive
producer of the show gonzo gonzo was
into bourbon and so
the same way that i was bringing wines
every night for people to try and stuff
people started bringing bourbons
um and other people started bringing
wines and then we started just doing
wines and bourbon every night and
you know i i'd always swore that i
wasn't gonna drink any other liquor
other than one
and here you are here i am having
crossed that line many many times many
times yeah it's a wonderful other side
of the line to be on yeah but but
there's there are similarities i mean
it's like it's got like the layers of
flavor and like you know you can really
spend a lot of time geeking out about it
in the same way people in the wine world
do that said um you actually
do a aggregate site as well correct yeah
whiskey raiders so uh raiders r-a-i-d
get it raiders and raiders uh yeah so
it's uh uh yeah it's a site that that
takes the reviews from the various
whiskey blogs um and turns them into a
number or grade
and then
takes them all puts out spits out one
number
so the reason i did it was because when
i got into whiskey
i was thinking they don't have what i
have in wine right in wine i can go to
like one place and see okay
these guys gave it this okay because you
know there's like three or four wine
places i want to see what they say about
it and whiskey there was no place to do
that to go and say oh you know what are
these different places saying about it
and that was the idea behind behind
whiskey raiders
well it's it's something you know we've
uh i think i was on like one of the very
first little deals we did a tasting on
there with you guys and i know howard
follows that i follow what jason does
hey they present this podcast absolutely
they do
yeah yeah yeah dan's involved in kind of
everything you know going on that uh
media wise that i've been fortunate to
be a part of so
um obviously the big question everybody
always wants to talk about here at
crimecom we've been asked a million
times is uh when live pd is coming back
yeah um you know without getting into
all the
everybody knows a story on when it went
off the air and
um you know
you yourself being the face of the show
and still obviously as active you know
as you are
multiple times a day out doing media
stuff
uh you know you've taken
uh
i don't know if i use the term abuse but
people have come after you about the
show thinking
you're the guy that makes all the
decisions and you're responsible for the
show whether it's on the air or not
right there's nothing that
pisses me off more than when people say
dan abrams sold out live pd yep or dan
abrams doesn't care about live pd well
hey let's back that up a little bit kind
of explain to the folks how that works i
mean
right obviously you're not in charge of
a production company well so i don't own
the production company but even the
production company didn't make this i
mean i mean i guess in theory they were
involved in the decision but the you
know this was um
this was a decision
made not by me i mean i was the i'm in
host of the show and yes i'm an
executive producer but it doesn't give
me any authority over whether the show
is on the air
what i've been doing since
is taking a lot of incoming from people
saying hey
what happened to live pd and you would
think based on its popularity that it
would be easy it'd be like well of
course it's going to come back you know
look it's a
it's a complicated show putting aside
the politics and all the all that stuff
from it it's a complicated show to do if
it wasn't complicated i'd put it on law
and crime
you know
you start you you
kind of spoke to this earlier you have
90 employees that it takes to produce
this show on friday and saturday night
right that's a lot of moving parts its
own and that's just the internal
production and i can say from being
there it's like watching a sporting
event well and then the technical piece
of it
which is now imagine you're in eight
different cities at once you're getting
in feeds there are four cameras in each
city
um
and you know you got to figure out how
to balance it etc i would say it's
even harder
it's more like
you're in the in a sporting event like
you know the the decisions that um on uh
sports networks they have to make when
they got eight games going on they're
like all right which game are we going
to go to etc but they've got to be con
unlike in sports in sports they kind of
know all right we're not going to the
louisiana game until blah blah blah here
we could be going to any of these eight
departments at any time
and that means there also have to be
people monitoring each one really
closely um so yes it is a very uh
complicated
uh show
and expensive and expensive it is
expensive yeah so that's why it's not
people say well you know why doesn't
just you know why don't you just pick it
up on law and crime and it's like
because we don't have you know the
resources to do that uh so it's got to
be
the place that you know where a live pd
type show and i say that because you
know who knows about the name etc um a
live pd type show
would have to be on a place that has the
the resources and has the the stomach
for it i mean there is going to be when
live pd comes back and i say when
because i am confident i've been saying
this for a while and people are getting
irritated at me because i keep saying it
but i am confident live pd is going to
come back
and when it does
there are going to be a lot of people
are going to say oh my goodness this is
awful this is horrible
uh this is pro this is propaganda this
is just exactly what we you know and i
don't share their view but let's just
stop right there i mean
it's as transparent as transparency can
be
well look you know there was an incident
that happened i mean let's be honest
there was an incident that happened and
it was awful yeah and you could argue it
wasn't transparent right and they're
right it wasn't
there in my view
that that you know it was a mistake yeah
but just because that window's tinted
the live pd i agree
because it's live pd i have to be so
careful you said to me it's as trans
transparent as transparent can be and i
know that if someone decides they want
to take out of context and i just go
yeah and i don't and i don't
specifically say that i recognize that
there was an incident where that was not
the case and by the way i didn't even
know that it happened at the time sean
didn't know it we didn't know
we didn't know anything about it so you
could argue even internally there was a
lack of transparency sure um so so you
know
so that's why because it's live pd and
everything can be nuclear about this i
got to pick my words carefully so i
can't just nod and go yeah it's as
transparent as transparent can be
but you know that incident and
well-documented the media has covered it
and things like that it's something
going forward
if when the show comes back it won't
happen it won't happen again yeah i mean
it was i i don't want to use the word a
lesson but
people that involved the lawyers the
production company
and so forth hey they're like hey man we
this was a
a mistake yeah not going to happen you
know if this situation
happens the same way it will be handled
ifpd comes back it's going to be
fundamentally
i should say if a live pd type show
comes back it's going to be
fundamentally
the same kind of show absolutely but
it will have some new
procedures in place
to ensure that you know things like
retaining tape etc are part of what they
do and so there can't be an argument as
was you know happened here where video
was was as a matter of policy
destroyed after a certain amount of time
that
that won't happen
and that's an easy fix
um
and um and you know and there i think
they'll be you know i would expect
there'd be some other smaller things but
look for live for a live pd type show to
work it fundamentally has to be
you know the show
you can't
change
the show and say oh we're going to start
doing
talk show where we're going to have
conversations about it's still got to be
focused on
police
they're the stars of the show
we are the
you know just the connectors the
commentators yeah but just sort of you
know but they're that you know the point
is you know there are people who
basically say oh
they make suggestions about basically
creating a talk show and i'm like i do
talk shows but that's not what this show
that's not the place there are there are
listen the the news whether it's
fox news on the right or msnbc on the
left they have their talk shows
concerning the topic of policing and
they bring their experts in or they
bring officers former officers social
justice people and all that and that's
not what life right pd or the you know a
show like that is right it's different
there are enough of them out there
already that do do that and i think
that's the beauty of it the spontaneity
of the show you never know what's going
to happen
you kind of tune in and you're like yeah
i think one of the things that i think
is pretty funny is you guys are taping
this live but you
what did you call it did you have you
have a delay
well yeah i mean that was one of the big
questions is is this thing on a delay
there is just like live pd there's a
small built-in delay for things and
there was one on that show um
but what would come across the screen
that the viewers at home would see
we're shooting it in real time in real
time we're seeing it for our first time
as it happens as well because it's
police work because you know there you
know there was an incident where someone
um shot themselves uh
it would have been it would it didn't
happen live because there was a delay um
and as a result you know that didn't
make it on air um
and um and that's you know and there are
there are instances where maybe an
undercover undercover officer will
suddenly show up on a scene where they
have to be careful i mean they're just
there are a few instances because it is
real police work with real people their
privacy issues you know someone starts
yelling and screaming phone numbers um
and starts saying blank person rape me
which has happened
you don't want that going out on the air
so so there has to be
a a bit of a delay more so than just a
second right as we have or a few seconds
as we have sometimes in in news but it
doesn't fundamentally change the live
nature of of what we're doing
and with what is coming out on the air
yeah you know i'll give you an example
during season one i started out on the
out on the streets in a car
and i had a deal where i came across a
guy that i dealt with prior um you know
to that incident and he starts talking
to me about some just as you were
talking about some confidential stuff
that you can't have on the air i mean
you know for his safety he's a he's a
gangster that you can't have other
gangsters people sitting at home
watching that and knowing hey this guy's
talking to the police so that was one of
the deals and i remember i turned right
to the producer that was we had a field
producer that was out there i said hey
this can't this can't be on it
let's be clear i mean one of the things
that you know
it is up up to the producers in the end
it's just what makes it on the air i
mean sean could say that right but and
but that doesn't mean that they're
necessarily going to listen to them
correct yeah that's i mean it's part of
the contract right you know
that they get final say but in a
situation like that where there's a
clear and compelling argument and it's
not just oh it makes us look bad right
that's the stuff where you you know
that's the stuff where it can't happen
but sean's saying this guy just said
stuff that's gonna get him killed yep
you know the producers are going to
inevitably um
agree to that yeah you know an example i
give just when people want to talk about
the live thing i'm like listen at
sporting events
there's people that streak naked and run
across the football field but you're
sitting at home watching the football
game on monday night football you never
see that because there's a delay there
enough that they can go hey we you know
let's cut that camera to show on the
sideline type of deal
well one of the things that's most
interesting about that is some of the
police departments you get
how do you guys go about finding these
police departments how do you
yeah what do you look for so
it's basically casting it
i mean look you look for the one you
look for a diversity in the departments
um you want different kinds of
departments you want big city you want
some rural you want sheriff you want
police uh
you want troopers you know having
different kinds of departments i think
because they do different kinds of stuff
um is good um you know we don't get to
decide which officers go out i mean sean
can tell you from behind the scenes that
the department decides yeah
yeah and so
listen i mean this
we have a pre-a pre-show meeting a
production meeting before every episode
and we sit in there and i don't want to
call it a lineup but we literally get
handed a piece of paper and it tells us
what departments are on and what
officers are riding that night and
that's the that's the first we know
about it and the people that are
involved in the production the
departments pick you know who they want
to have
uh representing their police department
on television and we have zero say about
it and you listen there's some officers
that right we have boring nights they're
officers who are not good characters
exactly exactly policing that's right
and that's exactly it and that's so
going back to you asking about the
departments it is you want to show the
diversity you don't want to just show
one type of policing that has happened
and that's why it's literally spread
from florida to washington or you know
from connecticut to southern california
it's going to show hey this is policing
in america and these are the different
things in different parts of the country
that these guys are dealing these men
and women are dealing with well i kind
of feel like i'm interviewing you guys
for a lot of pds yeah yeah i'm going to
roll this back a little bit so i
tell me about your first experience with
lab pd
um
you know when the uh when the crew came
in they kind of set up shop right there
in our office in the gang unit
and uh
you know just because it was a brand new
show
i don't know maybe a week or two before
it actually went on air i think they
started riding with us just to
for them to kind of start working out
some of the technical things of sending
this back to new york and how do they
get it out on air
and stuff like that and then we went
live we went live on a friday night and
it was for two hours
two hours flies by um the show
and correct me or feel free to jump in
any time dan you know it started
building up a uh a viewership pretty
rapidly over the first few weeks not but
you know it took some time it did it
took time yeah but it's not like
immediately it wasn't everyone was like
oh my god
no no and then they wanted to hey we're
going to try we're going to try a third
hour because it's
you know i don't want to say stories
police work is not a story it's not a
fictional created thing i mean they're
real events that are happening out there
uh you know as far as the profession and
that were happening on the show but
in policing you can have an incident
we'll just we'll say an armed robbery
you know that would happen well cops
might spend five hours
tracking down a suspect and so you that
is a it's a story in its sense of
watching it develop and come to you know
a conclusion so the show wanted to say
okay some of these things we're having
to go off the air that are still
happening we're missing out on you know
things that are happening so they wanted
to try a third hour so when a third hour
found out it was better for the show
yeah so pretty soon there was three
hours every friday and then i remember
the time hey we want to try a saturday
well i had saturdays off and i was not a
fan of it i was like man i'm already
giving up my friday night you know to to
be a part of the show because i work
typically during the day obviously we we
worked a lot of evenings anyways um but
so we tried to saturday night and again
it went well and it was friday and
saturdays every every weekend from then
on and occasionally a wednesday or a
thursday or a tuesday they throw an
episode in so
it it is you know a police officer's car
is his office
um that's like thinking about having
somebody two or three people just
sitting in your office documenting
everything you do it takes a little
while to get used to um you know just
having you and your partner and then two
guys sit in the back seat of your car
now i will say this
and i 100 mean this they don't
they can't ask to go to any type of call
that pops out on the radio they don't
ask to stop a car they don't ask hey
that person over there is you know
dressed interesting let's get out and
talk to them they have zero
input on any of that it's whatever the
officers are going to do or whatever the
radio you know directs that officer to
do the police radio
and then they just document it so the
only time
they are really talking interacting with
this is a call would go out on the radio
well they're not familiar with police
tin codes or something like that and all
of a sudden you know i hammer the gas
down and i start taking off to something
and they're like where are we going what
are we heading to adam and so you tell
them hey man there's a guys are in a
foot chase we're four blocks away
um and that's where
you know they would be able to then
because they're talking live to somebody
back in new york um and then they're
like hey
you know here in tulsa they're heading
to a foot chase we're a couple blocks
away and so that's when dan goes back to
what dan was talking about there's
that's how focused people have to be
to quickly make these decisions for us
to you know fast forward to back in
studio to go hey we're going to jump to
tulsa they're heading to a foot chase
right now gotcha well then let's fast
forward a little bit how did he end up i
know he did a couple of guest spots
right
who sticks yeah
yeah i mean look he can't we what we
were doing is we'd have different
officers who were in the field
come in
and
do
analysis talk about what's happening etc
sean was one of them um and you know he
took pretty naturally to it um
and uh
you know i think that that sort of led
to a more regular uh gig with him and it
ended up
in the end coinciding with probably
would have would have been his
retirement time anyway
um and so uh you know i think it all
ended up working out pretty well yeah i
remember you talking about okay so i'm
going to go i'm going to go up here and
i'm going to do this a little bit and
oh and then like i think a couple months
later he goes hey they want me up here
all the time
yeah it was it's a i mean i say it all
the time it was it's a fluke deal i mean
it was there was never a uh
you know i was never a kid college kid
or whatever that was oh i want to be on
television someday or anything like that
i wasn't
you know big in social media i wasn't
fascinated by all that stuff it was just
an absolute fluke deal
and speaking of that your path
getting into television is kind of
unique
yeah
because you're a well-educated guy yeah
i uh
you know i
had a that moment
where i had graduated from
fancy law school and uh was had a job at
a big new york law firm
and you know i had always you know i had
always liked the news business and
always really been interested in it
and uh i had you know done it in college
etc and when i was about about to enter
my third year law school i was like you
know god am i really gonna go and
because what you do is you work after
your second summer at a law firm and
they give you an offer so you know then
in your third year that you've got a job
coming right after law school
and law school is three years and
i was sitting there my third year law
school and i'm like the law firm was
great i was but i was like you know this
isn't really what i want to do and then
it happened that court tv started which
was covering they were like going to do
this new thing of covering live trials
um and i thought oh that could be cool
and so i went in as a production
assistant um so i had this you know
fancy law degree and i'm going in making
25 000 a year um as a production
assistant
um
and uh and went from there
and just you know when you say your
fancy law degree and i hope you don't
mind me saying that he's
duke for undergrad colombia if i'm
correct for law school so you know these
are big boy colleges and uh you kind of
have family lineage that's
tied into law yeah your father's a
well-known prominent a prominent
attorney up there your
sister
um her husband and so forth i mean
that's kind of in the family she's a
federal judge yeah
uh yeah no so so you know it was not uh
the typical road uh to take um
but uh but you know it is interesting
because in the in the
in the area of policing in the media
it does give me
the insight of the media bubble
right because you know i live with these
people in the media bubble right right i
don't pretend not to sort of be involved
i just don't agree with them on a lot of
the
stuff related to to policing but i think
it's important
to
to understand it
um the same way it's under it's really
important to understand
the perspective police officers um
and and it's not just the media you know
there would be people who would say well
dan you know you don't understand what
it's like to be a member of a community
that's and fair i i have not you know
not been part of uh
i've been very lucky in my life uh so i
i'm i think about that every day but
when it comes to policing and the media
um you know there is definitely a lot of
antipathy to the
police um in
in media circles well right now it's a
it's a popular thing to to you know
what click bait whatever the term we
want to use but that's we'll kind of
jump into everything you're doing now
because you are you are and you're a
personal friend of mine obviously and
i'm not saying this to just kind of you
know
applaud you i guess but you are
literally one of the busiest dudes
that's probably in media with everything
you're involved with and i mean you do a
serious exam show how many days a week
five right yeah every day
you have a prime time news show yeah
that's called dan abrams live standard
on news nation um
and
you know multiple books that you've
written they've been new york times
bestsellers
uh so you are and then your long crime
network which is right now just killing
it killing it exploding and you know
let's
some people out there might not be
familiar with either dan abrams live
right and just how is that different
from
your typical
primetime news show cable news show and
and talk about the long crime network
yeah so uh you know the theory behind
my show on news nation to some degree to
news nation as a whole
but but my show in particular is a sort
of more politically moderate but
opinionated show so some of the issues
around policing you know i will i tend
to be
pro-police doesn't mean in every case
doesn't mean that i can't look at
evidence in a case and i will say i
think this officer should be convicted
um that's not a hard thing to do i
always say to people
you know the best thing and you say this
all the time too the best thing can
happen to police is that the bad ones
are held accountable
and so
but i say that to say that you know
there are people on the more sort of you
know conservative side who probably
agree with me uh on that and then there
are other issues um you know uh that
where i'll be more
left-leaning
but the point is that that
the idea is that i'm just not coming in
rooting for a team
it's not and that's right now on cable
news it feels like all the major players
are rooting for a team
um and and there's a perception in the
audience that they're rooting for a team
and it's really important to me
to tell the audience look you may
disagree with me on this one you may not
but i'm not doing this i'm saying
because i believe it maybe you think i'm
wrong but i'm not doing this because i'm
rooting for
biden or trump or whoever it is
um well when you talk about that
polarity and that absolutes on different
news outlets i mean
is it all just coming down to money
yeah just pandering to their base yeah i
think it's a good business model right i
mean look i think that the folks who are
most of the folks who are on tv who are
doing opinion shows believe the stuff
they're saying right
but they also recognize
that if they don't i mean look what
happened with fox news right in the wake
of the 2020 election the minute fox
started highlighting the results of the
election being very clear that donald
trump lost
there were people who were like i don't
want to accept that and so they newsmax
and oan
started saying well you know come on
over here join us
um i say this not to get into politics
here but to talk about it from a sort of
like business perspective sure and
that's what i'm looking for yeah well
along that same vein the media you're in
the media bubble you've been in it yeah
you have a very pragmatic view of the
media you kind of live in the real world
in the media world
when did media diverge into this path of
polarity man
it's look it started um
probably
well look you ask conservatives and
they'll tell you that the media has been
left-leaning for decades for decades
right so so let's let's start there but
but in terms of the level of
obvious overt
partisanship
that we're seeing now you know i think
it it really hit
probably 20 years ago it started and i
think that it got a lot worse um
in 2016.
um and depending on which side you're on
you'll point the finger at somebody else
uh as to who's to blame for that sure
but but i think that's when it sort of
turbo charged in terms of having to pick
a side look i think cnn is the best
example of that in the sense that
they went all in on anti-trump and i and
i i mean all in in the sense of like
you know
sort of you know uh very aggressive
chirons on the screen insulting him and
this and that and so like there was no
even effort to sort of hide it yeah and
it became part of what they do
they became the leading anti-trump uh
network and that was a different path
for cnn right that was sort of msnbc's
lane uh before that and so now the two
of them ended up kind of battling that
out
all right sorry go ahead howard i think
that's unfortunate for the
country man it is it look it you know
what it's maddening
that and this is what i try to do on my
shows i have people on and disagree with
me right you should i i treat them with
respect
i try to say to them the first question
i always say to them is tell me what i'm
getting wrong yeah i'll do a whole
lead-in where i'll lay out my position
and i'll say all right tell me what i'm
getting wrong
you know there's nowhere else that's
doing that that's great you know well
and
obviously i mean i i you know i do some
law enforcement stuff on your show a
handful of nights a week and so i'm i'm
watching the show as it's happening
and
what i try to explain to people is yes
you know over on news nation is a
smaller cable channel
but
hopefully more and more people start
watching it because you do you say hey
what am i getting wrong but also you go
hey here's this topic of whatever it may
be that's going on right now and you you
jump and go hey this is what people on
the ride are saying about it and then
you go hey this is what people on the
left are saying about it and so you're
kind of you put out what the event is
give both sides and you let the viewer
kind of go
look at both sides i think one of the
most important things is transparency
which is telling them what i think about
it because that's what people are really
angry about i think about the media they
feel like they're all biased and they
won't admit it right right and they're
all these quote unquote journalists who
claim to not have opinions about things
i don't pretend to be that i stated them
look
here's where i'm coming from
here's what i think this side this side
blah blah blah but my take on it is
blank and a lot of the time i'll then
have someone on who will come on to tell
me why they think i'm wrong right well
there was an episode that i was on with
dan a few weeks back and
i thought i was going to have that
opportunity it was a prominent college
that had decided to get rid of police
officers from uh
from from some of their buildings and
remember harvard at harvard yes and i
was going to i don't want to say debate
but we we're going to have the
difference of opinions me obviously
saying how absurd that was and then one
of the people that was one of the
students there that was behind
getting the police removed from certain
parts of the campus and they chose not
to come on so it had been kind of fun to
yeah to have a discussion with a harvard
elite that way they've got some great
cops there yeah there's a lot of damn
schools in the boston area but uh damn
obviously we don't have a whole lot of
time i know you've got to move on but
talk about the law and crime network man
just how huge that has gone for you and
listen long crime network is how this
podcast is here yeah um dan and i you
know when when howard and i came up with
the idea and damn's who we reached out
to uh
real quick before we talk about the long
crime the name of this podcast is
cocktails and cocktails yes and we had
differences of opinions you and i did uh
you know the the legal people there um
with this name we are very very happy to
hear that we came to an agreement and we
get to keep it i had two issues with the
name all right the the the first issue
was a
sort of corporate one right which was
like you know we want to get people who
are going to
want to be associated with it and
advertise and this and that and i i was
a little concerned with the linking cop
stories to the you know make it seem
like you're drinking talking about cops
that one
you know that was part of it the other
part was
i just thought it was kind of a dumb you
did yeah yeah yeah no you thought i'd
say you would say it was corny yeah so
there are two there are two pieces to it
there's the corporate and then there's
just the personal and the personal was
that just i was like transparent i would
say
i'm transparent guys yeah yeah i think
the word you used was corny yeah it's
corny it's like
hey cocktails and cocktails yeah
and so so that would be we would have
these discussions and then uh poor sam
who was kind of middlemen in this thing
would have to get stuck between the
conversations and uh then they were like
how how stuck are you guys on this name
we're like man we're stuck on this game
we love it we think it's great and then
uh when the logo came up we were like we
love the logo and it's just as corny as
it is
um
it was also it was
the launch of the show also happened
right during some of the you know the
media backlash i also didn't want like i
i think what we agreed on in
transparency was that for the first
month or so that we would just call it
cop tales yeah and i just said you know
let's just launch it let's not get you
guys beat up by the by the media i know
right goes back to we're talking about
before i know
that i know what's going on in their
heads if they decide they want to go
after you they're going to go after you
about the you know also about the name
so for the first month we just called it
cocktails and we agreed well i will say
this we were bad kids yeah howard and i
were very bad
we referred to it as cocktails and
cocktails every episode it's fine yeah i
know we did not yeah
but but but the launch from a from from
the media perspective was cocktails
right let's back it up now is it still
corny yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
i know this thing is great yeah that's
great hey listen we got bottles with our
picture on it now so it's uh
it's got a thing all right so uh jason's
giving us a head here we've got about
seven minutes left uh
tell us about law and crime yeah so
long crime
is a number of things the the biggest
thing it is uh is a live network
that covers live trials um and one of
the great things is that we get in all
of these trials we have a live it's on
cable it's on you know ott meaning it's
on like sling and fubo and other
services all the major ott services um
out there and so you can watch live
trials but there's also programming at
night uh you guys air
at night um sometimes so um so we have
original programming um and that's a
great part of of what we do but there's
also a website called longcrime.com
which is now the biggest true crime
website in america
um and there's a production arm which
produces programming both for law and
crime and for others and it's really
become a big a big business um
and i think that you know i think that
part of that is recognizing that it's
not just a typical tv network right it's
a
next generation network it's focused on
you know social media youtube etc as a
really predominant part of how we do
what we do i mean just even speaking
youtube and by the way we have 12
podcasts now let's say 12 podcasts yeah
crime junkies another big one
let's be transparent yeah yeah let's
let's be uh so the the old
answer there was one there was one
called cocktails
[Laughter]
but yeah crime junkies another big one
you guys have on there and just speaking
of youtube just being part of the email
chains for for long crime you guys just
went over a million subscribers on there
i think it's close to 1.5 yeah so that's
i mean
it is just you guys are exploding uh out
there and of course you've still got
court cam yeah
i host court cam it's one of the shows
we produce and i host uh another show on
a e called taking the stand which is
about
um
people in trials who take the witness
stand in their own defense
and uh that the show is sort of centered
around around that
well i know a now retired police officer
that used to be on a television show
called live pd that would love to you
know jump another television show with
you whether you're behind it or we're
partnering up so just we are in case you
know something well
and and you know we are actively trying
to uh to make that happen that we are
yeah that we are
well dan man
been a pleasure always love you good
seeing you yeah so how did things go
last night at the uh the award banquet
here at crime con i didn't make it out
there it was great it was uh you know a
thousand people there um you know this
this these people this is a very
passionate community absolutely um and
it's it's it's cool to see it's you know
these are people who are really into
you know what i do um and so it's super
exciting no everybody's been fantastic
and i think next year it's in orlando
and i mean even when uh
live pd was on the air i remember there
was discussion that we were going to go
to it and well kind of be one of the
headliners it was even bigger than that
i mean oh yeah we were going to do our
own tour yeah that's it we had so we
were going to do our own conference we
did we had what five cities i think i
think we had five different we didn't
even worked out i mean the contract was
done yeah it was it was it was close and
then covet happened which kind of
it was it was close it never quite got
there but it was close and you know it
just shows you again
you know the live pd community
is
you know sort of like i was saying about
this community here
you know it's a super passionate one as
you know people are still every day
asking when is it coming back i miss it
yep um so
we're keeping up the fight
we have not given up two years
two years this month actually uh you're
in may right is it june yeah okay i mean
we're close yeah it's early june yeah
cheers
gentlemen thank you guys keep up the uh
awesome work it's fun it's a fun podcast
that's it we have a blast say cocktails
and cocktails cocktails
welcome to cocktails and cocktails on
that one we're out
few minutes to name anything else
you